Hey gang, welcome to Smartless. We are a sweet new podcast starring myself, Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman and Will Arnett. And we are complete idiots. So what we do is we bring on a guest and we ask them stuff and they make us smarter. Hopefully it's super cool. So please come with us. Enjoy the show. Smart. Liars.
嘿，伙计们，欢迎来到《Smartless》。这是一个很棒的新播客，由我本人、肖恩·海耶斯、杰森·贝特曼和威尔·阿奈特主演。我们都是彻头彻尾的白痴。所以我们要做的是请来一位嘉宾，问他们一些问题，让他们让我们变得更聪明。希望这会非常酷。所以请加入我们。享受节目吧。《Smartless》。
Smart. Liars. Smart. Liars. Smart. Liars. Smart. Liars.
《Smartless》。《Smartless》。《Smartless》。《Smartless》。
Now, listen, I need to say this before we get too deep into this. I am about to have a COVID test because it's 2020 and I get them done like once a week or every 10 days. We have to with the kids and mine just happens to coincide with us doing. So at some point during the podcast, I'm going to have somebody come in and she's going to come in and give me that's not true. Yeah.
听着，在我们深入探讨之前，我得先说这个。我马上要去做个新冠检测，因为现在是2020年，我大概每周或每10天就要做一次。我们得为了孩子们这么做，而我的检测刚好和录制时间撞上了。所以播客进行到某个时候，会有人进来，她会进来给我做……那不是真的。是的。
Why? Why does it have to be during our time? And what is COVID? Oh, bless him and his- Why does she have to do it during our time? Because it was- Bad scheduling? Bad scheduling, but a lot of things conspiring.
为什么？为什么非得在我们录制的时候？什么是新冠？哦，保佑他和他的……为什么她非得在我们录制的时候做？因为那是……时间安排不好？时间安排不好，但很多事情凑到了一起。
Cause tomorrow afternoon I'm busy. Uh oh, that's always boring. With you. Wait, what? Oh, you guys golfing? No, no, no, we have a business meeting. No, no, no, we're going charity. Oh, I see that. I got it, I got it, I got it.
因为明天下午我很忙。噢，那总是很无聊。和你一起。等等，什么？哦，你们去打高尔夫球？不，不，不，我们有个商务会议。不，不，不，我们要去参加慈善活动。哦，我明白了，我懂了，我懂了，我懂了。
I guess I'm busy too, yeah. Feeding kids. Busy. Making smiles. It's a charity meeting. I thought you were gonna say, after your COVID test, you were gonna have like a reveal party of the result. Oh yeah, you know, people get mad because I keep doing, on the subway,
我想我也很忙，是的。喂孩子。忙。制造欢笑。这是一个慈善会议。我以为你会说，做完新冠检测后，你会举办一个结果揭晓派对。哦，是的，你知道，人们会生气，因为我一直在做，在地铁上，
I used to do gender reveals all the time. I'd wear a trench coat and I'd just go, hey, you know? And I'd just reveal my gender to people. That know it's so dumb and people got mad for my gender reveals on the subway. Will next time you you have the results. I hear a female laughing so your guest already I can tell is a female or a fella who is happy might sound careful like a female yeah might sound like a female good for you good for you that's restraint look at look how much you've grown oh wait so let me guess I know it's a woman it is it's a really I don't
我过去经常做性别揭晓。我会穿一件风衣，然后走过去，嘿，你知道吗？然后我就向人们揭晓我的性别。那太蠢了，人们因为我在地铁上做性别揭晓而生气。威尔，下次你拿到结果的时候。我听到一个女性的笑声，所以我能看出你的嘉宾是一位女性，或者是一个快乐的家伙，听起来可能像个女性，小心点，像个女性，是的，可能听起来像个女性，为你高兴，为你高兴，那是克制，看看你成长了多少，哦等等，让我猜猜，我知道是个女人，确实是，我不知道
know if you can tell by her laugh because mostly people are laughing at what she's doing okay is it Phyllis Diller so she's a what she's doing. Okay. Is it Phyllis Diller? So she's a comedian. She's a comedian, well, I mean, she's a lot of things. Stand-up or actor? Let me, you ready for this? All of the above. She started as a stand-up, then got into acting,
你能不能从她的笑声中听出来，因为大多数人是在笑她做的事情。好吧，是菲利斯·迪勒吗？所以她是一个……她在做什么。好吧。是菲利斯·迪勒吗？所以她是个喜剧演员。她是个喜剧演员，嗯，我是说，她有很多身份。单口喜剧演员还是演员？让我，你准备好了吗？以上皆是。她以单口喜剧起家，然后开始演戏，
then did sketch, then did SNL, then did her own show. One, two Emmys is a hilarious, just all around hilarious person. She's got a brand new podcast that is killing it. Bella Stiller. Ladies and gents, Sean and Jason. Uh-oh. Sarah Silverman is on the show today.
然后做小品，然后上《周六夜现场》，然后有了自己的节目。获得过两座艾美奖，是一个非常搞笑的人，全方位都很搞笑。她有一个全新的播客，非常火。贝拉·斯蒂勒。女士们先生们，肖恩和杰森。噢哦。莎拉·西尔弗曼今天在节目里。
Hang on. Sarah Silverman! Woo-hoo! Woo-hoo! Look at that. Embarrassed! Great. Why are you embarrassed? Because you're smoking the skinniest cigarette I've'm embarrassed! That's great. Good. Why are you embarrassed?
等等。莎拉·西尔弗曼！呜呼！呜呼！看看那个。尴尬！太棒了。你为什么尴尬？因为你在抽我见过最细的烟……我尴尬！那太棒了。好。你为什么尴尬？
Why, because you're smoking the skinniest cigarette I've ever seen. It's a toothpick. Oh yeah, she's tough today. Oh, I'm so excited you're here. I know, how good is this? It's so cool. Look at this.
为什么，因为你在抽我见过最细的烟。那是一根牙签。哦是的，她今天很强硬。哦，我太兴奋你能来了。我知道，这有多棒？太酷了。看看这个。
Can you believe it? Nice going, Will. I know. You guys. Nice going. We're all such fans of yours. You're such a super comedy, hilarious person. There she is.
你敢相信吗？干得好，威尔。我知道。你们。干得好。我们都是你的超级粉丝。你真是个超级喜剧天才，太搞笑了。她就在那儿。
Will, what's your first question? Since you've had time to work on good questions, it's your guest. Let's have your best one right now. Okay. Sarah. Yeah? How's it going?
威尔，你的第一个问题是什么？既然你有时间准备好问题，这是你的嘉宾。现在就提出你最好的一个吧。好的。莎拉。嗯？最近怎么样？
Oh, that's good. No, listen. Gender reveal on the subway is the funniest joke, by the way. It's so dumb, right? It's so dumb. That's a great joke. Oh my god. I've been waiting to tell that for like four days. When you said it, you know when you hear something and you can't wait to tell a friend, you know? It wasn't quite that, but it was like almost that.
哦，那很好。不，听着。顺便说一句，地铁上的性别揭晓是最搞笑的笑话。太蠢了，对吧？太蠢了。那是个很棒的笑话。天哪。我等了大概四天想讲那个笑话。当你讲出来的时候，你知道当你听到什么东西，迫不及待想告诉朋友的时候，你知道吗？虽然不完全是那样，但差不多。
Can I tell you something? So I'm going to tell you this, Sarah. One of my favorite jokes that I have told many times over and over, or I've retold the scene which is people's least favorite thing to hear when you're like, hey, do you remember the scene where, was from your old program. So I'm going to start in the middle. From the Sarah Silverman program where you did on Comedy Central. Such a funny show. It's so good.
我能告诉你一件事吗？我要告诉你这个，莎拉。我讲过很多次的最喜欢的笑话之一，或者我重演过那个场景，这是人们最不喜欢听到的，当你像说，嘿，你还记得那个场景吗，是来自你的旧节目。所以我要从中间开始。来自喜剧中心播出的《莎拉·西尔弗曼节目》。真是个有趣的节目。太棒了。
And you did this bit, by the way, I don't know if you could do it today. It was the episode where you wanted some good. And you did this bit, by the way, I don't know if you could do it today, it was the episode where you wanted some good news so you decided to get an AIDS test. Right? Yeah. First of all, there are like 80 jokes crammed in this tiny scene. And you go, she goes, have you ever had unprotected sex? And you said, is there any other way?
顺便说一句，你演了这段戏，我不知道你今天还能不能演。那是你想要一些好消息的那一集，所以你决定去做艾滋病检测。对吧？是的。首先，这个小场景里塞了大概80个笑话。然后你说，她说，你有没有过无保护性行为？你说，还有别的方式吗？
Then she said, in the 80s, and you said... No, yeah, she goes, did you ever have unprotected sex in the 80s? And I go, oh my god, yes. And she goes, you did? You had unprotected sex in the 80s? And I go, oh, no, I thought you said in Haiti. So then she says, tell me how many times. And so you take a piece of paper and you start writing and you hand it to her and she says, tell me how many times. And so you take a piece of paper and you start writing and you hand it to her and she goes,
然后她说，在80年代，你说……不，是的，她说，你在80年代有过无保护性行为吗？我说，哦天哪，是的。她说，你做过？你在80年代有过无保护性行为？我说，哦，不，我以为你说的是在海地。然后她说，告诉我多少次。所以你拿出一张纸开始写，递给她，她说，告诉我多少次。所以你拿出一张纸开始写，递给她，她说，
what's that? And you go, that's the number. And she goes, there are two numbers. And you said, yeah, for the front and back. And she goes, they're the same number. And you said, yeah, I'm kind of OCD like that. It was like a domino effect of jokes. It just like started and it was just non-stop. Fuck me man. I've told that that's such a funny bit and it's
那是什么？你说，那是次数。她说，有两个数字。你说，是的，前面和后面。她说，它们是同一个数字。你说，是的，我在这方面有点强迫症。那就像多米诺骨牌效应的笑话。它就这样开始了，而且没完没了。去你的，伙计。我讲过那个，那真是个有趣的段子，而且
such a you're just everything about that scene was again I don't know I think people might be offended today. I don't know. There are a lot of problematic things looking back but you know such is comedy it's not evergreen. Right so so that's my thing is like, you've always been such a, I don't know, such a fucking stupid word, edgy, but you know, cutting it. Good for you, Sean. Thank you, thank you.
那是……关于那个场景的一切，再次，我不知道，我想人们今天可能会被冒犯。我不知道。回过头来看有很多有问题的地方，但你知道，这就是喜剧，它不是常青的。对吧，所以这就是我的观点，就像，你一直是一个，我不知道，一个该死的愚蠢的词，前卫，但你知道，很犀利。为你高兴，肖恩。谢谢，谢谢。
You're getting prayer hands, yep, go ahead. Prayer hands, prayer hands. That, what is it, it's always about the messenger of the joke, it's never really about the, so you can say like on the Sarah Silverman program, you could do a joke about AIDS like that and people embrace it and laugh because it's you saying it. So what do you think is the difference between you saying it and somebody else saying it and not getting away with it? It seems like you get away with a lot of stuff because you're so fucking funny, but some of it's pretty dark.
你得到了祈祷的手势，是的，继续。祈祷的手势，祈祷的手势。那个，它是什么，它总是关于笑话的传达者，从来不是关于……所以你可以说，在《莎拉·西尔弗曼节目》上，你可以讲一个关于艾滋病的笑话，人们会接受并大笑，因为是你说的。所以你认为你讲它和别人讲它却没能蒙混过关有什么区别？看起来你因为太搞笑了而逃脱了很多事情，但其中一些确实很黑暗。
I think it's the intention behind it. Like, this is a math term, but it's kind of like the absolute power of the joke. Like, especially back then, I always said the opposite of what I thought, you know, and that was the joke kind of. And then hopefully the truth transcends that I don't really feel this way,
我认为是背后的意图。就像，这是一个数学术语，但它有点像笑话的绝对力量。就像，特别是在那个时候，我总是说我所想的相反的话，你知道，那才是笑话。然后希望真相能超越我并不真的那样想，
not to break it down in the least funny possible way. But it is also interesting too, because like that comedy I did, you're right. It was like, oh, it's OK, because you know, I don't mean it. But then it also is kind of like we're liberal so we can say anything. So we can say, you know, the words that are unsayable or whatever, like, you know, I don't mean it. So I can say it like there is kind of like a liberal like douchiness about it, I think. And in retrospect, I know, I don't mean it so I can say it like there is kind of like a liberal like Doucheyness about it. I think and in retrospect. I mean, I don't know. It's a weird balance. I think you're right
不是要用最不搞笑的方式来拆解它。但这也很有趣，因为就像我做的那些喜剧，你是对的。就像，哦，没关系，因为你知道，我不是那个意思。但它也确实有点像我们是自由派，所以我们可以说任何话。所以我们可以说，你知道，那些不能说的词之类的，就像，你知道，我不是那个意思。所以我可以那样说，我觉得这有一种自由派的混蛋感。回想起来，我知道，我不是那个意思，所以我可以那样说，我觉得这有一种自由派的混蛋感。回想起来。我是说，我不知道。这是一种奇怪的平衡。我想你是对的。
I was thinking about that the other day Which is like what's been gone is things have gotten so serious because everybody who's not liberal is so serious and so dark and so real about their Negativity or hate or racism or whatever it is, that it's taken all of that away. You're like, I don't even want to joke about anything. A lot of things that are rough or maybe pushing boundaries because you feel like, I don't want it to be taken the wrong way because there are so many people who mean it.
我前几天在想这个，就是说，消失的是什么，事情变得如此严肃，因为每个不是自由派的人都如此严肃，如此黑暗，如此真实地对待他们的消极、仇恨、种族主义或任何东西，以至于它把所有这些都带走了。你会觉得，我甚至不想拿任何东西开玩笑。很多粗糙的或者可能在挑战界限的事情，因为你觉得，我不想被误解，因为有太多人是认真的。
Right. Yeah, there's not enough distance. You know, it's like so close. Like people go, oh, it's so funny. I saw like a comment in Spanish of something that I wrote and I go oh you know I have a fan that's Spanish you just let I press translate and it was just a why don't you stick to comedy and you know leave politics out of it. I was like oh. So wait I'm sure you've had your share of criticism like we all have like positive negative but is there someone in your life that mattered to you who said that you may have taken certain materials too far or something like that which of your friends have you offended Sarah and lost
对。是的，没有足够的距离。你知道，它太近了。就像人们说，哦，太搞笑了。我看到我写的东西下面有一条西班牙语评论，我说哦，你知道我有一个西班牙语粉丝，我按了翻译，上面写着为什么你不专注于喜剧，你知道，把政治排除在外。我说哦。所以等等，我相信你一定经历过你的批评份额，就像我们所有人一样，有正面的也有负面的，但你生命中是否有对你很重要的人说你可能把某些素材做得太过分了，或者类似的事情，你的哪些朋友被你冒犯了，莎拉，并且永远失去了？
forever I've actually kind of made friends that started out as like them calling me out mmm right interesting you know I would guess and please correct me but I would guess that one of the things that appeals to you about comedy, about thinking of funny stuff and crafting it into something, you know, in order to deliver to an audience, is about identifying that which makes some of us uncomfortable. As opposed to some people look, it seems to me, look at other things that makes them excited about comedy. With you, it seems like you have an affinity for, as do I, trying to identify the thing
我其实交了一些朋友，他们一开始是那种指责我的人，嗯，对，很有趣，你知道，我会猜，请纠正我，但我会猜，喜剧吸引你的地方之一，关于思考有趣的事情并将其制作成某种东西，你知道，为了传达给观众，是关于识别那些让我们中一些人感到不舒服的东西。而不是有些人看，在我看来，看其他让他们对喜剧感到兴奋的东西。对你来说，似乎你有一种亲和力，我也是，试图识别那个
that all kind of makes us a little bit uneasy because it only exists in our smallest place. And you want to kind of bring that out and amplify that and share a common sort of reference point. So, are you finding that you're frustrated that outside sources seem to be narrowing those borders and those walls and now you have to kind of think twice and three times about that? Or do you not listen to that?
让我们都有点不安的东西，因为它只存在于我们最小的地方。你想把它带出来，放大它，并分享一个共同的参考点。所以，你是否发现你很沮丧，因为外部来源似乎正在缩小这些边界和墙壁，现在你必须对那个三思而后行？还是你不听那些？
I think like what you said, edgy, or you know, I know it's corny or whatever, but it's like, you can't have it both ways. Like if you do something that is risky, you have to be risking something. Like there are consequences. Like you can't get mad both ways. Like if you do something that is risky, you have to be risking something. Like there are consequences. Like you can't get mad that there are consequences. And I don't mind, I like like when young people,
我想就像你说的，前卫，或者你知道，我知道这很老套或者什么的，但就像，你不能两全其美。就像如果你做了一些有风险的事情，你必须是在冒险。就像有后果。就像你不能两全其美。就像如果你做了一些有风险的事情，你必须是在冒险。就像有后果。就像你不能因为有后果而生气。我不介意，我喜欢当年轻人，
you know like students or whatever, like they teach me new language. I'm into that because I feel like they're always on the right side of history and I want to like learn new words and pronouns even though I fuck up all the time. Fire, by the way, is a new one for something that's good. Okay.
你知道像学生什么的，他们教我新语言。我喜欢那样，因为我觉得他们总是站在历史正确的一边，我想学习新词和代词，即使我总是搞砸。顺便说一句，“火”（Fire）是形容好东西的新词。好的。
That's not that new. No, it's brand new. It started yesterday. That's not new, granddad. I had a guy tell me on Twitter, it made me think about, you know, there's an ad that came out for Biden with Sam Elliott doing the voice for it. I don't know if you heard it. And so I just, I retweeted, I said the, the VO master, right?
那不是那么新。不，它是全新的。昨天才开始。那不新，爷爷。我在推特上有一个人告诉我，这让我想到了，你知道，拜登出了一个广告，山姆·艾略特配音。我不知道你有没有听过。所以我只是，我转发了，我说，配音大师，对吧？
Cause he's just like the voiceover idol of mine. Like he's so good. All I said was VO master and this guy responded stick to comedy. And I thought, wait a second. Do you do voiceovers well? Who's asking? You have to be one thing. You have to be the one thing I know
因为他简直就是我心目中的配音偶像。他太棒了。我只说了配音大师，这家伙回复说专注于喜剧。我想，等一下。你擅长配音吗？谁在问？你必须是一件事。你必须是我认识你的那一件事。
you as. Right. Yeah. Exactly. You are a monolith. And it was within my, and I'm like, I can't even comment on voiceover? Like, wait a second. Also, like whoever's saying that, what do they do for a job? Are they a critic? I hope that they are only a critic. I hope so too. So speaking of sticking to what you do, you started you started doing stand up when you were young, right? Like like a 17. Seventeen. That always blows my mind when stand up start. I know. How did you scare the courage? The more courage at 17, don't you?
对。是的。没错。你是一个整体。这在我的……我甚至不能评论配音？就像，等一下。还有，不管是谁在说那个，他们是做什么工作的？他们是评论家吗？我希望他们只是评论家。我也希望如此。所以说到专注于你做的事情，你很小的时候就开始做单口喜剧了，对吧？大概17岁。十七岁。当单口喜剧演员开始时，这总是让我感到震惊。我知道。你是怎么鼓起勇气的？17岁时更有勇气，不是吗？
I did. I was a bedwetter until I was almost 16. So by the time that I did stand up, but't you? I did. I was a bedwetter until I was almost 16, so by the time that I did stand up, but you know, nothing is humiliating. Nothing competes with that kind of humiliating. But how did you know how to write at that young of age? Like, how did you know how to craft and construct a joke? I mean, I wasn't good. You know, I just did it. I wasn't a good comedian. I liked it. Like jokes about, you know, I went did it. I wasn't a good comedian.
是的。我几乎16岁之前都在尿床。所以当我做单口喜剧的时候，但你不是吗？是的。我几乎16岁之前都在尿床，所以当我做单口喜剧的时候，但你知道，没有什么比那更丢人了。没有什么能比得上那种羞辱。但你那么小的时候是怎么知道怎么写的？就像，你是怎么知道如何构思和构建一个笑话的？我是说，我并不擅长。你知道，我只是做了。我不是一个好的喜剧演员。我喜欢它。就像关于，你知道，我去了……我不是一个好的喜剧演员。
I liked to like jokes about, you know, I went to a high school actually that was really, they'd have an assembly on Mondays and Fridays and they'd let me do like a couple minutes. And I had a math teacher that would let me like tell a joke at the beginning of every class as long as I shut up the rest of it. And it was nice. It was like, it was really encouraging. I studied piano, I know this is where everybody passes out. I studied piano and classical music when I was much younger
我喜欢关于，你知道，我实际上上了一所高中，他们会在周一和周五举行集会，他们会让我做几分钟。我有一个数学老师，他会让我每节课开始时讲个笑话，只要我剩下的时间闭嘴就行。这很好。这真的很令人鼓舞。我学过钢琴，我知道这是每个人都会昏倒的地方。我学过钢琴和古典音乐，当我更小的时候，
and I remember in high school, my dentist told me that he and his wife were throwing a Christmas party and I would, would I come over and play background music at the party on the piano. And I'm like, yeah, totally, wow. And serve drinks. Yeah, and the piano. And I'm like, yeah, totally, wow. And serve drinks. Yeah, and serve drinks. And wear this outfit.
我记得在高中时，我的牙医告诉我，他和他的妻子要举办一个圣诞派对，我会，我愿意过去在派对上弹钢琴作为背景音乐吗。我说，是的，当然，哇。还要端饮料。是的，还有钢琴。我说，是的，当然，哇。还要端饮料。是的，还要端饮料。还要穿这套衣服。
And can you park cars or? Do you mind wearing a mask? The point is when I was done, he handed me $100. And I was blown away that I got paid for a talent that I got something in exchange for the years I put into honing this craft. Do you remember the first time you got paid as a standup and what that was like?
你还能停车吗？你介意戴口罩吗？重点是当我做完的时候，他给了我100美元。我被惊呆了，因为我的一项才华得到了报酬，因为我投入了多年的时间来磨练这门手艺，我得到了一些回报。你还记得你第一次作为单口喜剧演员拿到报酬是什么感觉吗？
Did you report it? And do you remember how old you were? When I was 19, I did a road gig at a club called Joker's Wild. And what's the town that has Yale in it? But it's like besides Yale, it's gross. Okay, sorry, I mean wonderful. So it was like this low rung mob run place
你申报了吗？你还记得你多大吗？我19岁时，在一家叫“小丑狂野”（Joker's Wild）的俱乐部做了一场巡演。那个有耶鲁大学的城镇叫什么？但除了耶鲁，它很恶心。好的，抱歉，我是说很棒。所以那是一个低端的黑帮经营的地方，
called Joker's Wild. I was the emcee. For six shows, I got altogether $100. And they harassed me the whole time and kept asking me to do cocaine. And I had to find my own place to stay. And I stayed with these elderly cousins of friends of my mom's that were both deaf.
叫“小丑狂野”。我是主持人。六场演出，我总共得到了100美元。他们全程骚扰我，一直问我要不要吸可卡因。我得自己找住的地方。我和我妈妈朋友的远房表亲住在一起，他们都是聋子。
It was like a rough week. It was really odd. And you're all jitzed out too? Oh, so you're all jitzed out. No, I did not. I did not do cocaine but um yeah in the headliner that week I won't say is you probably wouldn't know him but he ended up kind of losing everything he was like at that point he was married he just had a kid and he was such a nice guy mostly impressions but then I heard a friend of mine was in NA with him and he
那真是艰难的一周。真的很奇怪。你也被搞得精疲力竭了吗？哦，所以你被搞得精疲力竭了。不，我没有。我没有吸可卡因，但是嗯，那周的压轴演员，我不会说名字，你可能不认识他，但他最终失去了一切，他当时结婚了，刚有了孩子，他是个很好的人，主要是模仿，但我听说我的一个朋友和他一起在戒毒互助会，他
did a brilliant thing you know comics are so dark they're very close to criminals you know but he he would go to open houses and use the bathroom and steal all their drugs you know all their own medications and stuff. Wow. My next question is what's the perfect balance for you from comedies? What do you like to do that balances you out on any particular day or week or month, hobbies or? I'm so boring. I love television.
做了一件绝妙的事，你知道喜剧演员都很阴暗，他们非常接近罪犯，你知道，但他会去参观开放的房子，使用浴室，偷走他们所有的毒品，你知道他们所有的药物之类的。哇。我的下一个问题是，对你来说，喜剧的完美平衡是什么？你喜欢做什么来平衡你在任何特定的一天、一周或一个月的生活，爱好什么的？我很无聊。我喜欢电视。
Television. Watching television. Ozark! Oh my gosh! There we go. I got it. Oh my god! Great interview, guys.
电视。看电视。《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）！哦天哪！这就对了。我懂了。哦天哪！很棒的采访，伙计们。
She hasn't said it's good yet. Let her finish. Ozark what? It's such a solid interview. My god, there we go. I got it. Oh my great interview guys. She hasn't said it's good yet. Let her finish Oh, what was our goal? So it's such a solid be of a show. No, no, it's a god I just I thought so anyway, you don't need to but I just am a big fan of all of you Like what most like individually I could go off of all of you. Like, but most like individually I could go off. But I just want to say you're in your, you know, all of your brilliant actors,
她还没说它很好呢。让她说完。《黑钱胜地》什么？这是一次非常扎实的采访。天哪，这就对了。我懂了。哦，很棒的采访，伙计们。她还没说它很好呢。让她说完。哦，我们的目标是什么？所以这是一个非常扎实的节目。不，不，这是一个……天哪，我只是……我反正这么想，你不需要，但我只是你们所有人的大粉丝。就像，大多数……单独来说，我可以谈论你们所有人。但是，我只是想说你们是，你知道，你们所有杰出的演员，
brilliant performers, but your directing is like it's really beautiful. And I thought season three was phenomenal. And that's all you get. That's a lot. Thank you. I will take it. That'll get me to sleep tonight. Shh. And Will, your, your, um, the Reese's commercials. That's all you get. That's a lot. Thank you. I will take it. That'll get me to sleep tonight.
杰出的表演者，但你的导演工作真的很美。我觉得第三季非常出色。这就是你得到的全部。那已经很多了。谢谢。我会接受的。那今晚能让我睡个好觉。嘘。还有威尔，你的，你的，嗯，里斯（Reese's）广告。这就是你得到的全部。那已经很多了。谢谢。我会接受的。那今晚能让我睡个好觉。
And Will, your, your, um, the Reese's commercials. Oh, Reese's. Yeah, Reese's. Sorry, not sorry. Unbelievable. So you like watching, uh, drama stuff or do you watch it all? What about like reality shows? Like what about Bachelor?
还有威尔，你的，你的，嗯，里斯广告。哦，里斯。是的，里斯。抱歉，不抱歉。难以置信。所以你喜欢看，呃，戏剧类的东西，还是你什么都看？那真人秀呢？比如《单身汉》？
Do you have like a guilty pleasure like that? I am watching The Bachelor with my lover. Yeah, and we have a lot of fun. My wife loves that. It's just fun. It's so dumb. I know. But it's so fun. It's just big laughs all throughout. But besides that, like dramas. Yeah. Do you want to act in one of those or do you just want to watch them?
你有那种罪恶的快感吗？我正在和我的爱人看《单身汉》。是的，我们玩得很开心。我妻子喜欢那个。这只是很有趣。太蠢了。我知道。但它太有趣了。全程都是大笑。但除此之外，比如戏剧。你想在其中演一个，还是你只是想看它们？
Yeah, I would like to act in one of those, but I love watching them. I think it's like watching comedy can be... When it happens, I'm like, I enjoy it. But it's never my go-to because it's just kind of a little more stressful than... Right. You know, watching a thriller or... I would say it's like, you know, doctors don't run home and watch Grey's Anatomy. Right, yeah, it's like that.
是的，我想在其中演一个，但我喜欢看它们。我觉得这就像看喜剧一样……当它发生时，我会，我享受它。但这从来不是我的首选，因为它比……有点压力。你知道，看惊悚片或者……我会说这就像，你知道，医生不会跑回家看《实习医生格蕾》。对，是的，就像那样。
You've never said that, Sean. That's a fucking lie. You've never said that. Sean always says that. He does. Yeah, but's like you've never said that Sean. That's a fucking lie. You've never said that Sean always says that he does Yeah, but a thriller. Yeah, I'd love to be like a Or like a tactical is that right like a born a born movie or like oh, yeah You know what I started? Recording because they've been playing them. I'm is a Old Columbus from the 70s and they're so good
你从来没说过那个，肖恩。那是该死的谎言。你从来没说过。肖恩总是这么说。他确实。是的，但是……你从来没说过那个，肖恩。那是该死的谎言。你从来没说过。肖恩总是这么说。他确实。是的，但是惊悚片。是的，我很想成为一个……或者像战术性的，那是对的吗，像《谍影重重》电影或者像，哦，是的。你知道我开始录制什么了吗？因为他们一直在播放它们。我是个70年代的《神探可伦坡》，它们太棒了。
Oh, they're like watching a 70s movie like they're on film and they Peter Falk, right? Peter Falk and the episode we watched was Ruth Gordon in a rare role as a rich lady I love her best. She's my favorite Harold and Maude. Yes, of course and my favorite movie is where's Papa? Every which way but lose, huh? Harold and Maude, yes. Of course. And my favorite movie is Where's Papa? Every Which Way But Lose. Huh? Every Which Way But Lose. With Clint Eastwood where she goes... And Any Which Way You Can.
哦，它们就像看一部70年代的电影，它们是在胶片上，彼得·福克，对吧？彼得·福克，我们看的那一集是露丝·戈登在一个罕见的角色中饰演一位富有的女士，我最爱她。她是我最喜欢的《哈洛与慕德》。是的，当然，我最喜欢的电影是《爸爸在哪里？》（Where's Papa?）。《虎豹小霸王》（Every Which Way But Loose），哈？《哈洛与慕德》，是的。当然。我最喜欢的电影是《爸爸在哪里？》。《虎豹小霸王》。哈？《虎豹小霸王》。和克林特·伊斯特伍德一起，她在那儿说……还有《金拳大对决》（Any Which Way You Can）。
Sure. Any Which Way You Can with one of my favorite lines in any movie when the orangutan is on the thing and she goes, what are you doing? Eating all the oreo scrap and all over the place. That's one of my favorite lines. She always leads with her thumb. Yeah. Oh.
当然。《金拳大对决》，有我最喜欢的电影台词之一，当红毛猩猩在那个东西上时，她说，你在做什么？吃掉所有的奥利奥碎屑，到处都是。那是我最喜欢的台词之一。她总是用拇指带头。是的。哦。
Let me ask you this. So, Sarah, I want to go back to when you started doing... Do you remember... Hi, you guys. Hi, Sarah. I'm just happy to see your faces. Sorry. Go on. No, no, no.
让我问你这个。所以，莎拉，我想回到你开始做……你还记得……嘿，你们。嘿，莎拉。我只是很高兴看到你们的脸。抱歉。继续。不，不，不。
We'll let it all this... We'll make it clean. No, we don't have to. I'm only asking questions because Sean gets really mad if we don't stick to asking questions. But... He doesn't like conversation. He doesn't like conversation. And then he feels like the people in the middle of the country in Wisconsin are mad if we're not getting information out of our guests.
我们会把这一切……我们会把它剪干净。不，我们不必。我只是在问问题，因为如果我们不坚持问问题，肖恩会非常生气。但是……他不喜欢对话。他不喜欢对话。然后他觉得威斯康星州中部的人会生气，如果我们没有从嘉宾那里得到信息的话。
So our guest today is Sarah Silverman just to remind everybody. Sean, you happy now? And Sarah, I just wanted, I was thinking about you being 17 being on stage and you're trying to write jokes and you were joking that like they weren't any good. But can you remember like your first joke that you thought was funny? That maybe still is? Yeah. Yeah. My friend Eric Noy said, Does my breath smell like tacos?
所以我们今天的嘉宾是莎拉·西尔弗曼，提醒大家一下。肖恩，你现在高兴了吗？莎拉，我只是想，我在想你17岁时在舞台上，你试图写笑话，你开玩笑说它们一点都不好。但你能记得你觉得好笑的第一个笑话吗？也许现在仍然好笑？是的。是的。我的朋友埃里克·诺伊说，我的呼吸闻起来像塔可吗？
And I said, I don't know, do you put shit in your tacos? That was in high school. But I found an old notebook, like I save all my notebooks. I found a notebook from when I was like 19 and there were jokes in there that were so bad like and reading it written, you know, it goes um and a lot of my jokes early on were like I don't know. I'm just. So it was like I don't know why my goldfish died.
我说，我不知道，你的塔可里放屎了吗？那是在高中。但我发现了一个旧笔记本，就像我保存了所有的笔记本。我发现了一个我大概19岁时的笔记本，里面有笑话，太糟糕了，就像读着它写的东西，你知道，它写着嗯，我早期的很多笑话都是，我不知道。我只是。所以就像我不知道为什么我的金鱼死了。
I put it in a tank... Beat... Top... A tank top. Yeah, sure. Do you have a set time each day that you dedicate to, all right, I'm going to stare at the wall. I'm going to think of stuff I can write down for a possible performance or script or whatever it is,
我把它放在一个坦克里……节拍……顶部……一个背心（Tank top）。是的，当然。你每天有固定的时间专门用来，好吧，我要盯着墙看。我要想一些我可以写下来用于可能的表演或剧本或任何东西的事情，
or do you just kinda just let stuff happen to you and you always have a little thing in your pocket and you could be at a red light, you can think of something and you write it down. Mostly the latter. When I'm my best self, I do, sometimes I'm just sitting in a chair and it really is like, I remember someone calling me and I was just sitting in a chair in my room
还是你只是让事情发生在你身上，你口袋里总有一个小东西，你可以在红灯时，你可以想到什么，然后把它写下来。主要是后者。当我处于最佳状态时，我会，有时我只是坐在椅子上，这确实就像，我记得有人给我打电话，我只是坐在房间的椅子上，
and that they're like, what are you doing? And I'm like working and I know I was being defensive, but I do feel like a lot of it is just sitting, you know, stillness. If you can. I thought about the title of your memoir. If you haven't got one already and I want you to consider, okay, goldfish in a Tank top that does sound like a comedian doesn't it sound like a comedian that would be
他们说，你在做什么？我说在工作，我知道我在防御，但我确实觉得很多时候只是坐着，你知道，静止。如果你能的话。我想到了你回忆录的标题。如果你还没有的话，我想让你考虑一下，好的，背心里的金鱼，那听起来确实像个喜剧演员，不是吗？听起来像个喜剧演员，那会
great you have to put the ellipses in between tank and top goldfish in a tank dot dot dot turn page flip over top and then in parentheses get it right Lol jkjkjk Jk as far as the eye can see Sir I have to ask the cliche question to another funny person like what do you like favorite food? What the fuck happened to you as a kid that made you funny? Well, I mean, I think I was extremely her suit, you know, I was growing up in New Hampshire Really? I didn't know Jews. I didn't, you know, I didn't go to,
很棒，你必须在背心和顶部之间加上省略号，背心里的金鱼，点点点，翻页，翻过来，顶部，然后括号里，懂了吗？哈哈，开玩笑的，开玩笑的。开玩笑的，直到视线所及。莎拉，我必须问另一个有趣的人那个陈词滥调的问题，比如你喜欢什么最喜欢的食物？你小时候发生了什么让你变得有趣？嗯，我是说，我想我非常多毛，你知道，我在新罕布什尔州长大。真的吗？我不认识犹太人。我没有，你知道，我没有去，
like a lot of people go, oh, all the Bar Mitzvah season and all that stuff. I didn't have any of that. Like my parents are atheists. They call themselves agnostic, to be more polite. Or Jewish, to be even more polite. But like, there weren't Jews. So we, like my sister says, we thought being Jewish
就像很多人说，哦，所有的受戒礼季节和所有那些东西。我没有那些。就像我的父母是无神论者。他们称自己为不可知论者，为了更礼貌。或者犹太人，为了更礼貌。但就像，没有犹太人。所以我们，就像我姐姐说的，我们以为是犹太人
just meant being a Democrat, because that's how we were different in New Hampshire. You know? But I think because of that, I was like, I was really hairy too, and... Wow. Yeah, like my dad goes, you know, you want your dad to just think
只是意味着是民主党人，因为那是我们在新罕布什尔州与众不同的地方。你知道吗？但我认为正因为如此，我像，我也真的很毛，而且……哇。是的，就像我爸爸说，你知道，你希望你的爸爸只是认为
you're so beautiful, and he does, but he was like, in in high school he goes, if you want to spend a summer getting electrolysis, I'll pay for it. And I was like, why would I do that? Jesus. Oh, no, never mind. He really just meant it to be nice, but then I think he was horrified, because I was like, why would I do that?
你很漂亮，他确实这么认为，但他像，在高中时他说，如果你想花一个夏天做电解脱毛，我会付钱。我说，我为什么要那样做？天哪。哦，不，没关系。他真的只是想表现得好，但后来我想他被吓坏了，因为我说，我为什么要那样做？
We should be acknowledging this, by the way. I'm sorry. Well, you know, you don't need to do the brain scratcher anymore. Why? Yeah, I want to be thorough. Did they just stick a thing up your nose for the? Yes. The shallow ones are thorough as so is a saliva one now.
顺便说一句，我们应该承认这一点。抱歉。嗯，你知道，你不需要再做那个脑部抓挠了。为什么？是的，我想彻底一点。他们刚才是不是往你鼻子里插了个东西？是的。浅层的很彻底，唾液测试现在也是。
I mean, if it doesn't, dude, if it doesn't hurt, if there's no pain, then it's not fucking valuable. Have you not learned that lesson in life? That's what my dad said right before. My dad was right when he said, God, you what the fuck is wrong with you you'll be nothing You're not listening to your crime Right in between the times that he never told me he loved me Interesting about that. So, you know how that like makes people
我是说，如果它不，伙计，如果它不疼，如果没有痛苦，那它就不该死的有价值。你还没学到人生中的那一课吗？那是我爸爸在那之前说的。我爸爸说得对，当他说，天哪，你这该死的怎么回事，你什么都不是，你不听你的……就在他从没告诉我他爱我的时候。关于那个很有趣。所以，你知道那怎么让人们
Go into show business like my mom only she just read People magazine and she didn't look up from it. She didn't come to my games. She didn't you know, so it's like I think a part of me wanted to get into People magazine. You know what I mean? Right. Right. And I think all of us have I'm sure that yes. Sarah, you mentioned that your parents didn't go to your game. My dad did.
进入演艺圈，就像我妈妈，她只是读《人物》杂志，她没有从上面抬起头来。她没来看我的比赛。她没有，你知道，所以我想我的一部分想进入《人物》杂志。你知道我的意思吗？对。对。我相信我们所有人都有，是的。莎拉，你提到你的父母没去看你的比赛。我爸爸去了。
What game? What sport did you play? Every sport. I was you know, listen, I'm not bragging. I was a fast pitch pitcher for the state of New Hampshire. No, come on. Of softball. And not to minimize it.
什么比赛？你玩什么运动？每项运动。我，你知道，听着，我不是在吹牛。我是新罕布什尔州的快投投手。不，得了吧。垒球。不是要把它最小化。
And, you know, and I played soccer and I played basketball. I still play basketball, although I haven't since COVID. And now I'm like, do I still play basketball? Because like my bones are so rickety now. But when you do play, it's not you're not going down to like the local park and doing a pickup game. You have an organized game. A bunch of your friends get together.
而且，你知道，我踢足球，我打篮球。我仍然打篮球，虽然自从新冠以来我就没打过了。现在我像，我还在打篮球吗？因为我的骨头现在太脆弱了。但当你打球时，你不是去当地公园打野球。你有组织的比赛。你的一群朋友聚在一起。
I have gone to pickup games and I do play pickup games. But the two games I've been playing out here for the past couple years, I don't know anyone there outside of that game. What's the difference between a pick up game and a game? It's all strangers, yeah. You just show up and you say, hey, I wanna play. All right, well maybe I'll sign up for one.
我去过野球场，我也打野球。但在过去几年里我在这里打的两场比赛，除了那场比赛之外，我不认识那里的任何人。野球和比赛有什么区别？都是陌生人，是的。你只是出现，然后说，嘿，我想打球。好吧，也许我会报名参加一个。
Yeah. But the last time I played outside, I played with this guy. We smoked pot together. You know, he was adorable, whatever. Thank you. And then we were all playing. And then at the end of the game, we finished and that guy had left a little early. He had taken like five different people's car keys.
是的。但上次我在外面打球时，我和这个家伙一起打。我们一起抽了大麻。你知道，他很可爱，什么的。谢谢。然后我们都在打球。然后在比赛结束时，我们完成了，那个家伙走得有点早。他拿走了大概五个不同人的车钥匙。
No way. And then pressed them to see what went boop boop and then got in one and stole one of the guy's cars. Wow. This is the cute stoner. He was all, he's all stoned up. He's the guy's cars. Wow. This is this is the cute stoner. He's always all stoned up. He's all weeded up. Yeah. Well, I like to smoke pot when I play basketball because I
没门。然后按了它们看看哪个会发出“哔哔”声，然后进了一辆车，偷走了其中一个人的车。哇。这是可爱的瘾君子。他全……他全吸嗨了。这是那个人的车。哇。这是……这是可爱的瘾君子。他总是吸嗨了。他全吸大麻了。是的。嗯，我喜欢在打篮球时抽大麻，因为我
become incredible or terrible. But it's a grab bag. I'm willing to. Oh, hang on. Hang on. We'd love to get you to repeat that for a PSA if we could real quick. Just hi. I'm Sarah Silverman. You know, when I play basketball, I feel marijuana enhances my game
变得不可思议或者糟糕透顶。但这就像抓阄。我愿意。哦，等等。等等。如果我们能快速录制一个公益广告，我们很乐意让你重复一遍。只是嘿。我是莎拉·西尔弗曼。你知道，当我打篮球时，我觉得大麻增强了我的比赛
or puts me into a ball. But either way, it's worth the risk. But you also like to smoke it when you're not playing basketball. I like to have a puff at night. And that's nice. A little night night puff puff. Now, do you follow professional basketball? Are you a Laker fan?
或者让我进入状态。但无论哪种方式，这都值得冒险。但你也喜欢在不打篮球时抽它。我喜欢晚上抽一口。那很好。一点点晚安抽抽。那么，你关注职业篮球吗？你是湖人队的球迷吗？
You know, I like watching it. I mostly like watching like a close game in the last half last quarter I'm not I don't have like a right team that I'm obsessed with or something it's tough to watch the first three quarters like any underdogs I mean but then again I also like the Warriors just cuz I love Steve Kerr and yeah you know he's cool and I like the Lakers and I like the Celtics but only just because of various reasons So Sarah your your your resume is so crazy because not only you're incredible stand-up
你知道，我喜欢看它。我大多喜欢看最后半场最后四分之一的势均力敌的比赛，我没有那种我痴迷的球队什么的。看前三节很难，就像任何弱队，我是说，但话又说回来，我也喜欢勇士队，只是因为我喜欢史蒂夫·科尔，是的，你知道他很酷，我喜欢湖人队，我喜欢凯尔特人队，但只是因为各种原因。所以莎拉，你的简历太疯狂了，因为你不仅是不可思议的单口喜剧演员
But you've been part of some just great memorable shows, you know SNL Iconic shows I should say SNL Mr. Show Larry Sanders I mean, it's incredible that you got to be part of all these things that, for somebody like me, were shows that really kind of spoke to- Are you gonna cry? I'm trying to. Keep it together.
而且你参与了一些非常棒的、令人难忘的节目，你知道《周六夜现场》，我应该说是标志性的节目，《周六夜现场》、《小品秀》（Mr. Show）、《拉里·桑德斯秀》（Larry Sanders），我是说，你能参与所有这些对我这样的人来说真正触动了……你要哭了吗？我在努力。坚持住。
Just give me a second, I'm trying to fucking cry. Jesus, you just broke it. Now I'll never get there. Now I'll never get there. But these are shows that that like, you know, Mr. Show and Larry Sanders, they showed me, I was like, oh wait, I want to do that kind of shit. Yeah, they're like comedy gold shows.
给我一秒钟，我正试图该死的哭出来。天哪，你刚才把它打破了。现在我永远到不了那里了。现在我永远到不了那里了。但这些节目，就像，你知道，《小品秀》和《拉里·桑德斯秀》，它们向我展示了，我想，哦等等，我想做那种事。是的，它们就像喜剧黄金节目。
Oh my God, yeah. Like, yeah, set the standard. I mean, I got to be on all of those are iconic shows that I had nothing, you know, I was like, zeleg. I just got very lucky and ended up in a... Not true. I'm not being modest.
哦天哪，是的。就像，是的，树立了标准。我是说，我能参与所有那些标志性的节目，我什么都没有，你知道，我就像个“变色龙”（Zelig）。我只是非常幸运，最终进入了一个……不是真的。我不是在谦虚。
I just, you know, I had nothing to do with creating the, you know, I mean, but yeah, it is. I've been in a lot of like very culty Star Trek Voyager. I know. I love that. Wait, what was your time like at SNL and do you watch it now? Yeah, I watch it. I watch it and I'm a fan of it.
我只是，你知道，我与创造那个毫无关系，你知道，我是说，但是的，确实是。我参与了很多非常邪典的《星际迷航：航海家号》。我知道。我喜欢那个。等等，你在《周六夜现场》的时光怎么样，你现在看吗？是的，我看。我看，我是它的粉丝。
We can take the pause out in post. No, no, no, no. I mean, I had the year that I was there, I would never want to take back. It was like hard and it was long and it was frustrating and you know, but I got along with everybody, you know, and stuff. It was really a different time, you know. I mean, it was, I mean, they didn't have computers. Like we wrote our sketches on legal pads
我们可以在后期把停顿剪掉。不，不，不，不。我是说，我在那里的那一年，我永远不想收回。它很艰难，很漫长，很令人沮丧，你知道，但我与每个人相处得很好，你知道，之类的。那确实是一个不同的时代，你知道。我是说，它是，我是说，他们没有电脑。就像我们在法律垫上写小品，
and gave it to a room of typists. Right. Wow. Well, how did you like living in New York? I love New York, yeah. I moved there when I was 18. I love New York. I love just walking through the streets. Do you wish you still lived there?
然后交给一屋子的打字员。对。哇。好吧，你喜欢住在纽约吗？我喜欢纽约，是的。我18岁时搬到那里。我喜欢纽约。我喜欢只是走在街上。你希望你还住在那里吗？
Well, why do you, because I'd love to live there, but I have to live here for other reasons. I'd love to live there too, but I mean, the last time I had an apartment there it was $450, you know, I lived on a five-floor walk-up where I you know, I We there was a guy who lived on our floor We had our own bathroom, but it was a building that had a lot of like padlocked Bathrooms in the hallway that the apartments shared. It was a real dark kind of place.
好吧，你为什么，因为我很想住在那里，但我因为其他原因必须住在这里。我也很想住在那里，但我是说，我上次在那里有公寓时是450美元，你知道，我住在五楼的步梯房，我，你知道，我……我们那一层住着一个家伙。我们有自己的浴室，但那是一栋有很多像走廊里锁着的浴室的建筑，公寓共享。那是一个真正黑暗的地方。
And then this guy who just got out of prison lived in on our floor. And my roommate and I were walking downstairs and he was walking behind us with a friend and he dropped a box of bullets. Bullets were just running down our legs, running through our legs down the stairs. And neither of us acknowledged it. We just acted like it was not happening. We were so scared. That's hilarious.
然后这个刚出狱的家伙住在我们那一层。我和我的室友正走下楼，他和一个朋友走在我们后面，他掉了一盒子弹。子弹就在我们的腿上滚，穿过我们的腿滚下楼梯。我们俩都没有承认。我们只是表现得好像它没发生一样。我们太害怕了。那太搞笑了。
Sarah, who do you find absolutely hilarious? Either growing up or now, who you're just like, oh my God, I can't get enough of blank because they're so funny. So many people I know if I stared off. Have you seen Kate Berlant? She's incredible. I love Tegna Taro.
莎拉，你觉得谁绝对搞笑？无论是成长过程中还是现在，你只是觉得，哦天哪，我怎么看都不够某某，因为他们太搞笑了。很多人，我知道如果我盯着看的话。你看过凯特·伯兰特（Kate Berlant）吗？她太不可思议了。我喜欢泰格·诺塔洛（Tig Notaro）。
I love Zach Galifianakis. I love Kyle Dunigan. This guy Kyle Dunigan. He's just, you know, other people that just make you, you know. Or like... Zach, Zach's like that for me. Zach kills me. He kills me. So funny. And then he's just got this huge heart too. you know he's just like a good such a solid lovely Person and he's so funny. You know, that's I like what about back in the day somebody who made you laugh that Well, I guess you can't really say who made you laugh back then but based on how your sense of humor has changed now
我喜欢扎克·加利凡纳基斯。我喜欢凯尔·杜尼根。凯尔·杜尼根这个人，他就是，你知道，还有其他人也会让你，你知道。或者像……扎克，扎克对我来说就是那样。扎克让我笑死。他让我笑死。太搞笑了。而且他还有一颗宽广的心。你知道他就是一个很好、很稳重、很可爱的人，而且他非常幽默。你知道，我喜欢那种，回到过去，有人让你笑得那么开心，我想你不能真的说出当时是谁让你笑的，但基于你现在的幽默感已经改变了。
Kind of doesn't I mean there's certainly television shows and movies that I thought were funny back then that I would watch today and go, oh no, that doesn't hold up. Or my sense of humor has just changed. Yeah, I mean, I've gone so many directions. Like my friend Mark Cohen years ago, when I first started, he put a nickel on his head and said Jewish Ash Wednesday, and I cried because I was so sensitive and then I went like 180 degrees you know but I'm the same inside you know but like I was so upset
某种程度上并没有，我的意思是，肯定有一些电视节目和电影，我当时觉得很有趣，但今天再看会觉得，哦不，那已经过时了。或者我的幽默感已经变了。是的，我的意思是，我经历了很多方向。就像我朋友马克·科恩多年前，我刚开始的时候，他在头上放了一枚镍币，说这是犹太人的圣灰星期三，我哭了，因为我太敏感了，然后我转了180度，你知道，但我内心还是原来的我，你知道，但我当时太难过了。
by that you know. Oh really? Yeah an example of how people change people's tastes change and you kind of have you find yourself trying not to factor that in when you're thinking of stuff that might be best suited for something that needs to appeal to a wide audience because the people who are financing this don't want it to appeal to a narrow audience? Do you have to fight that urge? Well, I mean, that's why I think I prefer to be niche. Right.
因为那个，你知道。哦真的吗？是的，这是一个关于人们如何改变、人们的品味如何改变的例子，当你考虑到那些可能最适合需要吸引广泛受众的东西时，你会发现自己试图不把这些因素考虑进去，因为资助这些项目的人不希望它只吸引狭窄的受众？你必须对抗那种冲动吗？嗯，我的意思是，这就是为什么我认为我更喜欢小众。对吧。
You know what I mean? Yeah. You know's there's a lot of rules in the mainstream Right that's why I'm doing this podcast now Yeah, and Called the Sarah Silverman podcast and the one cool thing about it is like even if you're on cable or streaming or something I mean you can really say anything I think I said fuck way too many times in the first few episodes because I felt so free And you have to have the kind of get those same lessons that you have when you do stand-up where it's like Now it's just gratuitous. It's lost any power. It isn't cool You're using it as a crutch
你知道我的意思吗？是的。你知道主流中有很多规则，对吧，这就是为什么我现在做这个播客，是的，叫《莎拉·西尔弗曼播客》，它的一大酷点是，即使你在有线电视或流媒体上，我的意思是，你真的可以畅所欲言。我想我在前几集里说了太多次“他妈的”，因为我感到太自由了。你必须像做单口喜剧那样吸取同样的教训，就像现在这只是无谓的。它失去了任何力量。这并不酷，你把它当作拐杖。
But I had to kind of learn it over again because I was suddenly so excited to get to say anything I wanted that I was like fucking this and fucking that and I listened back and I was just like, yeah, yeah, yeah. What I always thought you did such a great job of doing you do it when you were like on a panel like on a guest on a talk show or whatever you found ways to I think a lot of people you were for a long time considered kind of like dirty or you would do you would dress jokes up you you never knew what you trojan horse like you'd come in and you dressed up and be kind of super bright about it and then the punchline would be really dark and you found a way to constantly it's kind of going back to Sean I feel I sound like an old man like you were edgy but you found ways to push the boundary and you didn't necessarily swear but you did not shy away from making jokes that were hit really hard?
但我不得不重新学习，因为我突然太兴奋了，可以随心所欲地说任何话，以至于我一直在说“他妈的这个”、“他妈的那个”，我回听的时候，我就觉得，是啊，是啊，是啊。我一直认为你做得很好的一点是，当你在小组讨论或脱口秀节目中做嘉宾时，你找到了方法，我想很多人长期以来认为你有点“肮脏”，或者你会包装笑话，你从来不知道你会用特洛伊木马，你会进来，打扮得漂漂亮亮，表现得非常聪明，然后笑点会非常黑暗，你找到了一种不断地——这有点回到肖恩的话题——我觉得我听起来像个老头，你很前卫，但你找到了推动界限的方法，你不一定说脏话，但你不回避讲那些非常深刻的笑话？
I never felt dirty. Like everyone would be like, she's a putty mouth and she's dirty. And I guess I am, but like, I never feel that way because I was raised in a house where you used just, the words weren't taboo, you know? So it's not like I swear a lot really. It's not like I use technical language or explicit, maybe.
我从来没觉得“肮脏”。就像每个人都会说，她是个满嘴脏话的人，她很肮脏。我想我是，但我觉得从来没有那种感觉，因为我是在一个家里长大的，在那里这些词并不是禁忌，你知道吗？所以并不是我真的说了多少脏话。可能并不是我使用了技术性语言或露骨的词汇。
Right, you didn't say fuck a lot. You didn't do that at all. Like you found a way to bring people to a punchline that was potentially really, they hadn't heard it before and it was kind of dangerous and you were kind of pushing the boundaries. Can I ask you this? So are there any kind of, Jason asked you if you want to do like a drama or anything
对，你并没有说很多“他妈的”。你根本没那样做。你找到了一种方法，把人们带到一个他们以前没听过的笑点，这有点危险，你有点在推动界限。我可以问你这个吗？所以有没有，杰森问过你想不想演戏剧之类的
like that, but are there any like comedy people for reals that you would want to work with or comedy directors that you think like, oh, I can- You know, I haven't done a lot of comedy. Well, this is the thing is the things I've been in in comedy, like in movies, it's like, this has changed a lot, but since, you know, it's the angry girlfriend or the angry roommate or the sleazebag executive, but it's like, so I go, after a while I go, I just don't even want to be in comedies
之类的，但有没有什么真正的喜剧演员你想合作，或者你认为的喜剧导演，你会想，哦，我可以——你知道，我没做过很多喜剧。嗯，问题是，我参与的喜剧，比如电影，这已经改变了很多，但自从，你知道，就是那个愤怒的女朋友，或者愤怒的室友，或者卑鄙的高管，所以过了一段时间我就想，我甚至不想演喜剧了
because the access I have to comedies is, I can't be a comedian in a comedy playing a straight role. It doesn't, it's stupid of me. It doesn't, I don't make money from doing movies. I lose money making movies. Of course, yeah, of course. I get the least amount of money. I can't be on the road. You know, so that's why it's like dramas or something where I'm in like someone else's domain is just makes sense. I just want to play the out. If I'm in a comedy, I want to be funny in that. Right. And otherwise, you know, I just want to do interesting things. You know, I like acting, but I like doing everything.
因为我接触到的喜剧，我不能在喜剧里扮演一个正经角色。这没意义，我这样做很蠢。我拍电影赚不到钱。我拍电影是在亏钱。当然，是的，当然。我拿到的钱最少。我不能在路上跑。你知道，所以这就是为什么像戏剧或者我在别人的领域里的东西才有意义。我只想演戏。如果我在喜剧里，我想在里面搞笑。对。否则，你知道，我只想做有趣的事情。你知道，我喜欢表演，但我喜欢做所有事情。
Sarah, I don't even know where to go. I mean, we could talk to you all day. It's so fun having you here. You've been talking for so long. I can't imagine. I'm so sorry. We're taking a lot of your time. Very generous. I'm so happy to be just seeing you and talking to you. Likewise.
莎拉，我甚至不知道该说什么。我的意思是，我们可以和你聊一整天。有你在这里太有趣了。你已经说了这么久了。我无法想象。我很抱歉。我们占用了你很多时间。非常慷慨。我很高兴能见到你并和你交谈。我也是。
But we'll wrap it up. Let's someone wrap it up. We're going to wrap it up. But we're going to say you're an absolute delight. You are a comic titan. I'm going to say that. I find you to be so fucking consistently hilarious. You've made me laugh so many millions of times.
但我们要结束了。让某人结束它吧。我们要结束了。但我们要说你绝对是一个令人愉悦的人。你是一位喜剧泰斗。我要这么说。我觉得你一直都他妈的非常搞笑。你让我笑了无数次。
So thank you. Royalty. Yeah. Royalty. Doesn't it make you feel all day? I remember when Joan, when you go, Oh Joan, you're a legend. She'd be like, fuck you. I'm still vital. You know, like it makes you feel done.
所以谢谢你。皇室成员。是的。皇室成员。这不会让你整天都感觉很好吗？我记得当琼，当你去说，哦琼，你是传奇。她会说，去你的。我还很有活力。你知道，这让你感觉自己还没完蛋。
Yeah. The next thing I do, you know how like your agent will go, ooh, but we got with or and for the credits. And you go, who cares? Why is that a thing? I want and introducing. That's really... Sure. I want them to fight for that.
是的。我做的下一件事，你知道你的经纪人会怎么说，哦，但我们得到了和或者为了演职员表。然后你会说，谁在乎呢？为什么那是个事儿？我想要“特别介绍”。那真的……当然。我希望他们为此而战。
My thing I keep going to is I'm asking my... I'm like, I want to fight for... In advance, fight for my position in the memoriam segment on like the Emmys and stuff. I wanna get- Oh, I'm already working on my reel. I wanna get the final, yeah. Final card. Yeah. Fuck, and I wanna bring down the fucking-
我一直坚持的事情是，我在问我的……我想要争取……提前争取我在艾美奖等颁奖典礼上的纪念环节中的位置。我想得到——哦，我已经开始制作我的片段了。我想得到最后的，是的。最后一张卡片。是的。他妈的，我想把那个该死的——
Do you know the song, Will? Do you know the song you wanna play? Five Dollar Footloan. Five Dollar, Five Dollar Footloan. I love that fucking song. We love you, Sarah. Thank you, Sarah. Bye, Sarah, thank you.
你知道那首歌吗，威尔？你知道你想放的那首歌吗？《五美元脚长》。五美元，五美元脚长。我喜欢那首该死的歌。我们爱你，莎拉。谢谢你，莎拉。再见，莎拉，谢谢。
Bye, thank you. Bye, Sarah Silverman. Bye, thanks so much. So funny, always, you know, there's that gross word again, but always edgy, dark. Like, she's the kind of comedy you choose when you really want to, it's like truth comedy. I always thought of her, and she's one of the cool kids.
再见，谢谢。再见，莎拉·西尔弗曼。再见，非常感谢。太搞笑了，总是，你知道，那个恶心的词又出现了，但总是前卫、黑暗。就像，她是那种当你真正想要时会选择的喜剧，这是真相喜剧。我一直认为她，她是酷孩子之一。
She was just so funny in such a great, real way. You're like, shit, man, I just don't wanna fuck up around her, she's so funny. I don't wanna be unfunny at any moment. I don't wanna be a fucking loser. Shit, you guys are so stupid to even think that, and then I just don't even get out of my car. I'd love to go see her do standup. I don't think to be unfunny at any moment. I don't want to be a fucking loser. You're so stupid to even think that and then I just don't even get out of my car. I'd love to go see her do stand-up. I don't think I've ever... I saw her do a stand-up at the Improv in Melrose and her opening joke was about rape.
她以一种非常棒、真实的方式表现得如此有趣。你会觉得，该死，伙计，我只是不想在她面前搞砸，她太搞笑了。我不想在任何时刻变得不幽默。我不想成为一个该死的失败者。该死，你们甚至想到这一点都很蠢，然后我甚至没下车。我很想去看她表演单口喜剧。我不认为在任何时刻变得不幽默。我不想成为一个该死的失败者。你们甚至想到这一点都很蠢，然后我甚至没下车。我很想去看她表演单口喜剧。我不认为我曾经……我在梅尔罗斯的Improv看过她表演单口喜剧，她的开场笑话是关于强奸的。
Just to sort of drop the flag and say, here it comes. So you have to be a fan and be open-minded, but I am and I'm a huge, huge fan. Well, I think, you know, and she made such a great point. She's made a lot of jokes that like has taken people back over the years or whatever, but she's right. It's all about intention and her intention is good. She's a good person and she's going the right direction
只是为了放下旗帜说，它来了。所以你必须是一个粉丝并保持开放的心态，但我就是，我是一个超级超级粉丝。嗯，我想，你知道，她提出了一个很好的观点。多年来她讲了很多让人们感到惊讶的笑话，但她是正确的。这一切都关于意图，她的意图是好的。她是一个好人，她正朝着正确的方向前进
and she wants, I think that, that sometimes she has to make jokes like that to kind of shed light on the other side. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. And that's her style. Yeah. And I love it. I respect it. And she's got a new podcast, the Sarah Silverman podcast, and it is great, of course. I've heard it. It's fantastic. Yeah, it's super good. And she's a stone-cold babe. Yeah, she's she's don't go babe. She's babe. She's a stone-cold babe And you know what the thing is? Yeah, we can say that the third thing is Smart. Bless. Smart. Bless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且她想要，我想，有时她必须讲那样的笑话来揭示另一面。嗯哼。嗯哼。那是她的风格。是的。我喜欢它。我尊重它。她有一个新的播客，《莎拉·西尔弗曼播客》，当然很棒。我听过。太棒了。是的，超级好。而且她是一个冷酷的美女。是的，她是，她是冷酷的美女。她是美女。她是一个冷酷的美女。你知道那件事是什么吗？是的，我们可以说第三件事是聪明。保佑。聪明。保佑。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。